these women in misrata are knitting hats
and scarves for men at the frontlines
it's a small gesture but it's part of a
big campaign to help the UN recognized
government repel fighters loyal to
warlord Khalifa Haftar they are
positioned 100 kilometers away and could
attack at any moment women in Libya
don't fight with guns but in their
unique way are fighting every battle we
feel like we're part of what's going on
feel like we're helping to defend our
country in our city yes it's kind of
were supporting each other we feel like
we're doing something we're not just
sitting there watching TV and listening
to the news many of these women have
sons at the frontline and some know the
bitter reality of the risks
each has lost a son or a brother Halima
lost one son during the revolution in
2011 and her last surviving son
23 year old Abdul Hameed was killed last
Sunday in the fight to defend the town
of Abu Ghraib I lost my son's for my
country but it was very painful losing
them they died defending their land and
honor but I have to be honest that
didn't take away the pain
we are tired of war it took Ali my
little brother he was engaged and we
were planning the wedding for him but he
went to fight and he became a martyr
instead for them there is closure of
sorts for hadiza there is not instead
pictures of his disfigured courts were
posted on social media by his killers
with music added
[Music]
I need to get my son's body so I can
bury him I don't know where he is and
what they have done to his body where
they have thrown it
why won't they give us the body we just
want to bury him her son Muhammad
Mustafa was on the front lines when he
was killed a month ago his body has not
been recovered it's rare for women in
Libya to speak so publicly but many are
suffering from the wars effects UN
studies have shown that around 30
percent of people in conflict zones are
likely to suffer from some form of
mental illness and women will suffer
more than men but in Libya there's no
structure in place to help them deal
with that trauma these children are all
suffering from war related trauma but
Libya is struggling to find enough
qualified mental health workers and
funding to help them let alone four
women confidently and amitin some have
inner mental issues where they don't
want to leave the house
or to work there are many cases where
they become isolated and alone they
don't want to do anything and they treat
their kids with anger if they are able
to get out and meet others they become
more relaxed but that's not so easy for
women to do in this conservative society
they often stay home battling their
grief and trauma on their own Toni
Berkeley al Jazeera Misrata